ladies and gentlemen winner is
erdmann bei marinade
[applause]
over the past ten years the
lux
film prize of the european parliament has given film culture in europe more
visibility and made european
films more popular with the
citizens of our eu i am therefore
very glad that i
the three
films that we saw in the finals this year are
entitled to award this prize again this year, reminding
us that what
connects us as europeans is
much stronger than the things
that separate us, the three films from the
finalists finalists here are were
produced show us that we
can only build a better world around
us if we actually take care of the people who
are in our immediate vicinity
toni erdmann shows a
father's attempt at his estranged daughter
in an absurd and  to rediscover the level of senate
hilarious confrontation
by  the subtitling of the three
final films of the looks film award in
the 24 official languages ​​of our union helps
the european parliament to make this
remarkable film accessible in all 28
member
states, thus reaching cinema lovers all over
europe, which
probably would not have been possible in this form without our support
i hope  that we can continue this good vision and
this important mission of our
cultural work that started ten years
ago with success in the
years
to come thank you very much for your attention
[applause]